you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
plans for a clean air zone in manchester
put on hold as farmers claim they'll be
unfairly hit with the cost
questions raised over the efficiency of
carbon capture technology used to reduce
emissions from hydrogen production
the stunning first pictures from a deep
sea coral reef discovered off the coast
of tahiti
and how penguins could be the canaries
in the coal mine for climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now air pollution contributes to at
least 1
200 premature deaths in greater
manchester every year
but councillors there have asked the
government to put the second phase of a
proposed clean air zone on hold
following a backlash from farmers and
local businesses who say they'll be
unfairly hit with the costs of upgrading
vehicles katerina vitotse has more
sheep are jade hutchinson's life and
livelihood this is caroline
they've all got names every single one
of them
the scene is rural but this area is in
greater manchester and under new clean
air zone rules jade will have to pay 10
pounds a day to use the truck she moves
her sheep in
the cost she says would wipe out her
profits and she doesn't qualify for a
green vehicle grant
i'm not allowed the funding because i'm
not a big enough business uh my vehicle
that i have um can't be traded in
because it's not come from an original
dealership i bought it second hand
because that's all i could afford if
they're thinking about people's lives
they shouldn't be affecting people's
lives by charging them and taking the
livelihoods away from them
air pollution levels in some areas of
greater manchester are dangerous the
government ordered and local authority
implemented clean air zone will address
that but thousands of small businesses
say they simply can't afford it
there are 1
200 premature
deaths in greater monster every year
from polluted air so you can't just say
oh no it's not an issue it is a big
issue
but what you've got to do
is
take that step fairly
it's about getting to clean air as
quickly as we can but enabling people to
come with us on that journey
local authorities are now asking for the
government to pause the plans
this may be an issue in greater
manchester right now but really we're
going to be seeing similar problems
developing in many other places over
many other green related initiatives as
this tension develops between
government-led climate-friendly policy
and the people who say they're the ones
that are having to pay
but people who live in some of those
heavily polluted areas say the cost is
worth it like 12 year old maxim who
lives in the city centre the pollution
makes his asthma worse and six months
ago he had a big and frightening attack
at school
it was kind of like two minutes of
live or die because
vin haley is the only thing that kind of
stops me
from
having an asthma attack it kind of shows
how selfish some people can be by just
caring about money more than caring
about other people and other children
cop 26 the un climate conference brought
big global issues into the spotlight but
here this very local problem shows just
how hard winning a greener future will
be
cataracts is sky news in manchester
now hydrogen will be a crucial fuel in
the future because unlike fossil fuels
it doesn't produce damaging emissions at
the point of consumption when you burn
it water is the only by-product so it
could provide a sustainable future for
heavy industry for aviation and for
shipping but it's how hydrogen is
produced that really matters to the
planet
now according to a new report seeing
exclusively by sky news one of the
world's only facilities that uses carbon
capture and storage technology to reduce
the emissions of producing that hydrogen
still has the same carbon footprint as
over a million petrol cars and emits far
more greenhouse gasses than it captures
so let's just explain a bit about the
different ways of producing hydrogen
well grey hydrogen makes up the majority
of current production and it's made from
fossil fuels and generates carbon
dioxide and methane emissions
green hydrogen is the opposite and clean
zero carbon it's made by using wind or
solar to split water into hydrogen and
oxygen gases but right now it's pretty
rare because it's an inefficient and
expensive process
well now lots of effort is going into
blue hydrogen and it's made with fossil
fuels but technology is used to capture
most but not all of the carbon dioxide
emissions for storage underground or for
under the sea now in theory this should
mean that it's less polluting than gray
hydrogen well skies helen and smith is
here to tell us more about a particular
plant in canada so helena what can you
tell us well a report's been issued into
one of the only sites in the whole world
that currently does this that currently
uses carbon capture and storage
technology alongside hydrogen production
now the plant in question is in canada
in alberta it's owned and operated by
shell it's been around since the 80s but
it was traditionally an ordinary
refinery it creates hydrogen that it
then uses to refine oil sands in 2015
shell added on a carbon capture and
storage facility it said as part of a
sort of demonstration project to see how
well this technology worked now global
witness the lobby group they've looked
into the site and they say that the
emissions from it are actually still
very high so the carbon capture and
storage part has prevented around five
million tons of carbon dioxide from
escaping into the atmosphere but it's so
it's prevented that from escaping but
it's allowed a further 7.5 million
tonnes to escape so much more than it's
captured it also says that the carbon
capture rate is actually only about 48
and then once you include supply chain
emissions and things like that that
falls down to about 39 so according to
global witness big red flags about this
technology big question marks about
whether we should be investing in this
or instead putting that money towards
more green solutions green hydrogen as
you explained in your introduction now
for shell's part uh context they say is
important here that carbon capture and
storage was retrofitted onto the site
and there are now technologies coming
through which are much better at this
that have carbon capture rates of up to
90 potentially even up to about 96 so
they say this kind of uh sort of ed
retrofitting job that they did is not a
proper example of blue hydrogen they say
that global witness is wrong in its
analysis that it's comparing apples and
pairs and that they are putting money
into this better technology experts sit
somewhere in the middle and say this is
you know blue hydrogen mark one but we
should learn lessons from it the debate
matters because there's plans for blue
hydrogen facilities in the uk
it's important plays an important role
in the government's blue hydrogen
strategy global witness says it's a big
opportunity to take another look at some
of those plans helen thanks very much
indeed
and we're going to be talking about what
role hydrogen can play in the energy
transition a bit later in the programme
with dame julia king who sits on the
committee on climate change and mike
berners-lee an expert in carbon
footprinting
so now let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news and
householders are losing around 40 pounds
a year because of cuts to climate
policies over the past decade that's
according to new analysis from carbon
brief the report shows that energy bills
in the uk are nearly 2.5 billion pounds
higher than they would have been if
green subsidies and incentives which
were scrapped in 2013 had been kept now
these include subsidies for energy
efficiency and onshore wind
a vast iceberg has melted around the
sub-antarctic island of south georgia
shedding
billion tons of fresh water the a68a
berg was about a quarter of the size of
wales when it snapped off a large ice
shelf in antarctica more than three
years ago
scientists at the center for polar
observation and modelling are now
working to assess its full environmental
impact
to indonesia and 40 critically
endangered turtle hatchlings have
waddled towards a new life in the wild
the olive ridley and hawksbill turtles
which are at risk of extinction were
rescued from beaches on bali by
conservationists they say just five in
every thousand sea turtles can lay eggs
making programs like this vital for
protecting the species
now a newly discovered colony of
penguins in antarctica could give
insight into how climate change is
impacting the region the gentoo penguins
were found on an island off the eastern
coast of antarctica previously thought
to be too icy for the animals well
earlier i spoke to louisa cassen from
greenpeace who's on a boat off the coast
of antarctica and i started by asking
her how significant the discovery is
this is the most southern the most
southerly point that we're finding
gentoo penguin colonies of this amount
of of breeding penguins so up till now
uh scientists had just found one
solitary
nest of uh gentoo penguins
normally this species prefers more
northerly warmer climates and yet as the
sea ice has changed around this side of
the eastern antarctic peninsula it's
made it more possible for them so seeing
these these 75 gently penguin chicks is
a clear sign of the climate crisis
affecting this region well yes and to
what extent then can penguins act as an
early warning system if you like for
ecological change in antarctica the
penguins are what we call a sentinel
species that means they give a really
good indication of the broader
environment around them and the state of
that the last time greenpeace came to
the antarctic we looked at chinstrap
penguins around elephant island and
found astonishing declines of up to 77
uh in the last 50 years so that was
again a clear sign of the rapid changes
and now this time we're looking at gen 2
penguins again because they are normally
found more north the fact that they're
able to expand further south and breathe
successfully further south is again on
this eastern side of the antarctic
peninsula sending worrying signs about
just how rapid this region is changing
and has been impacted by climate change
and you said that it's a sign that more
action needs to be taken we saw at cop26
governments around the world updating
their targets for reducing emissions
beyond that what more do you want to see
happening well as well as actually
increasing their their target so that
they're aligned with 1.5 degrees we also
need to make sure that in our oceans
we're creating vast areas that are off
limits to industry so that wildlife has
a better chance to adapt and build
resilience to the impacts of climate
crisis
to tahiti now and an extraordinary
underwater find a coral reef has just
been discovered in pristine condition in
unusually deep water it's giving
scientists hope that there could be more
marine ecosystems that haven't been
damaged by pollution and global warming
skies katie barnfield reports
a discovery as beautiful as it is
hopeful
this huge reef filled with rose-shaped
corals was found by scientists off the
coast of tahiti
unusually it's in pristine condition
unharmed by pollution or people well
it's exciting because it's uh it's a
healthy reef and uh you know
if you look at the stories it's it's
quite um
going the opposite we have lost about
half of our coral reefs in the last 70
years
and it's really the stuff that makes you
dream and it makes you really understand
the beauty and the treasure of the uh of
a marine environment in the ocean
index
the reef was discovered by a team of
unesco scientists using state-of-the-art
diving equipment that allowed them to
stay deeper for longer periods
you
after 200 hours of diving they measured
the reef at three kilometers long and
stretching down to 70 meters below sea
level
that makes it one of the world's largest
at this depth and raises the prospect of
more reefs waiting to be found
more dives are planned in the coming
months to study the reef and the marine
life that has made it their home
but its discovery shows how little we
still know about our underwater world
katie barnfield sky news
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
member of the committee on climate
change dame julia king and leading
expert in carbon footprinting and
director at small world consulting mike
berners-lee to discuss whether clean air
zones can be made to work
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
member of the committee on climate
change dame julia king and leading
expert in carbon footprinting and
director at small world consulting mike
berners-lee say good evening to both of
you very nice to see both
so manchester's council has asked the
government to press pause on plans for
an extended clean air zone the science
is clear and i think it's fair to say
that everyone agrees for the need for
clean air but there's much debate over
how it should be done and who ends up
paying so julia manchester council wants
a review of their clean air zone plans
but is this kind of scheme the right
approach do you think for tackling
pollution
i think it's a very important approach
for tackling pollution
of course as we move towards net zero in
2050
pollution
from vehicles will reduce as we
decarbonize those vehicles but of course
that's not fast enough um for people
like the young man with asthma that we
saw whose health is being affected today
particularly in those
high congestion regions um in a big city
like manchester
but mike it does leave people with that
choice of either upgrading their
vehicles which they say will be really
expensive or paying more to come in and
out of manchester and when we've seen
inflation up to 30-year highs businesses
are squeezed so you can see why this is
going to be tough for people
yeah i mean on the one hand it's
clear-cut that diesel cars in
uh in city centers are you know terrible
not just for climate but also for the
you know the serious impact that they
have on the life expectancy of everyone
uh in that city but on the other hand
yeah we need to implement policies where
as much as possible nobody gets caught
out by them
in principle at least a climate levy
raises a fund and if you're clever with
the money that you have from that fund
you ought to be able to use it to make
sure as far as possible that some that
that fewer people are caught out so it's
what you do with the money that you
raise from a climate levy that uh
that makes it um viable for people
do you think that's that's right julia i
mean what's what's the the best way of
making sure that the air is clean but
without putting that really tough
financial squeeze on people
well i think i think um tim makes a
really good point there that that if you
are charging people to come into the
city centre because they have a heavily
polluting vehicle um it seems a very
good idea to use that tax effectively
for a fund to help small businesses for
example to change to electric vehicles
so mike do you want to expand on that at
all you say a clever use of the funds
but but how can you use them more
cleverly
so for example we heard earlier on your
program somebody talking about how you
know they can't afford to you know spend
the extra money for an electric vehicle
instead of buying a new diesel car for
example well you know maybe you could
use some of that fun to support that
kind of greener purchase of the new
vehicle so that you know there are ways
you know of you can't always get it
perfect but there are ways of making
sure that by and large nobody you know
nobody gets caught out by this in a big
way and we've all got to be remembering
you know that the kid you had on the
program earlier you know those diesel
cars in city centers
really do
uh you know take away significantly from
the life expectancy of the people in the
area we estimated about 12 minutes of
life expectancy taken away from the
population of a city for every mile a
diesel car drives in a traffic jam
through that city so that's a huge
impact on life
and julia i mean i think anybody anyone
driving a vehicle would have real
sympathy with anyone that's suffering
from pollution but there are so many
other
conflicting interests aren't there and
people need to earn a living they need
to put food on the table for their own
children
um yes but i think i think
what uh tim was suggesting is a is a
scheme that makes sure we can help
people to make that transition and we
also need to remember of the huge
benefit to our health system the huge
reduction in cost to the health system
if we have less asthma and less people
suffering from the kind of pollutants
that vehicles um and indeed our gas
central heating
and other things emit in our cities
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we and just imagine not feeling
guilty about booking a long-haul flight
or at least not having to worry about
the emissions that it'll create that is
in theory at least what could happen in
the future if hydrogen can be produced
cleanly and at scale but there are big
doubts about the technology involved in
getting that hydrogen
cleanly enough now mike i know that
there are lots of different colors of
hydrogen depending on how you produce it
blue hydrogen is one of those different
methods and that involves using fossil
fuels to produce it but then capturing
the co2 emissions from that process do
you think that is a viable option for
the future i noticed that the german
government is setting a lot of store by
hydrogen in the future but it doesn't
think blue hydrogen should be part of
that vision what do you think
well we need to be clear that hydrogen
as a whole has a huge part in the clean
energy transition so
for storage of energy for we need to
work out how to how to generate it we
need to work out how to store it uh we
need to work out how to transport it and
then we need to sort out all the uh all
the ways of using it for everything from
airplanes potentially to ships to use
for steel making so there are many
different hydrogen technologies we need
to develop
and in a way you know they all come
together at once so we need to have a
sufficient supply of hydrogen in order
to be able to roll it out to all those
uses um that we need it for and if
there's a crunch point on
generation of hydrogen then i can
imagine as an interim step that blue
hydrogen
might in theory uh be you know a way of
plugging that gap but certainly for the
long term green hydrogen is a far more
elegant solution
and the technologies for that are coming
along nicely the electrolysis to create
uh green hydrogen you know will
is coming together which will allow us
to generate it at scale in the sunniest
places in the world you know and the
windiest places in the world so long
term it's definitely green hydrogen in
theory at least there's a potential
argument for blue hydrogen although at
the moment it looks very problematic
using it as a in any way a lower carbon
form or you know it's it's pretty well
as high carbon as fossil fuel at the
moment for the reasons that you've
you've outlined in your program already
so far
and i'm going to cut in sorry mike to
cut you off just gonna get julia's take
on this as well if that's okay because
what do you think then julia should we
just be putting all our concentration on
green hydrogen which uses renewable
energy only to produce it i mean
obviously it's the ideal solution but
but it's really expensive and
inefficient at the moment isn't it what
do you think we we have to be practical
and pragmatic about this um in order to
get to net zero in the uk
we have to um increase the size of our
electricity system by probably about two
and a half to three times and that's
assuming that about half our hydrogen is
green hydrogen and half is blue hydrogen
if we want to make all of that hydrogen
by 2050 green hydrogen then we in the
next 30 years we probably have to
increase the size of our electricity
system by a factor of about four i think
that that really is unrealistic the key
thing is we've got to really focus on
ensuring that blue hydrogen has very
high rates of carbon capture we need to
be up at 95 percent uh carbon capture in
the production process for blue hydrogen
in order for it to be part of our
solution to reaching net zero by 2050.
very briefly mike am i likely to get on
a hydrogen-powered plane anytime soon do
you think
it's the technology for that is a long
way off but it will would require
complete redesign of aeroplanes ammonia
using hydrogen to generate ammonia might
be an easier solution but uh low carbon
flying is sadly quite a long way off at
the moment i won't start booking my
tickets yet
okay we will have to leave it there
sorry to cut you off julia we're out of
time but judah king mike berners-lee
thanks both very much indeed
and that's it from me but tomorrow i'll
be joined by climate justice activist
michaela loach and chairman and founding
director of climate change think tank
e3g tom berg but for now thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]